johnson johnson was founded by three
brothers in a small shop in new
brunswick new jersey 128 years ago first
product making patches that deliver
medicines directly to the skin
1894 saw the introduction of Johnson's
baby powder last year some twenty two
million containers were sold in nineteen
twenty a J&J employee invented a novel
product for his wife when she burned
herself while cooking today over 2
billion band-aid adhesive bandages are
sold in the US that's at least six for
every man woman and child in the country
J&J is the world's biggest healthcare
products company 275 businesses and 60
countries with 1 billion people globally
using J&J items every day
it's Remicade anti-inflammatory
medication was one of the world's top 10
selling drugs in fiscal 2013 generating
6.7 billion dollars in sales more than
half the company's revenues come from
outside the US and that's growing Bridge
NJ offers green tea Listerine for
consumers in China and Malaysia in 1898
J&J received the first patent to produce
dental floss last year the company sold
enough in the u.s. to wrap the earth 30
times